[Music]
hello how are you greeted by natalia lancelot
and with her brief informative of
snow hymns in Spanish a man is dead
after a shooting occurred near
sam's town the police are still on the
trail of the suspect the detectives
said that this occurred in a
bus stop on butter high
way no additional details at this time
the street was closed
while authorities investigated the
incident the
las vegas metropolitan police department is
also investigating another death but
in downtown las vegas a man
was found  dead inside his
apartment overcome save near
las vegas return
information about the suspect is still unknown and they send
more financial aid to end the
pandemic just as he heard the
health district will receive more than five and a
half million dollars from the center
to  disease control and prevention
this money will help with
additional testing  it is education
vaccination clinics for the
most vulnerable communities Hispanics
and African Americans within
Clark County are part of the groups most
affected by the cover and now we turn
to the weather forecast we will have
temperatures reaching a maximum of 69
degrees for today with some clouds for
tonight we will go up to 72 degrees
by friday afternoon however
next week we will stay in the
60s so pack your coat nice
day greets you natalia lancelot and with her
brief informative about them now in
spanish